others can either such that these  [ __ ] with your siblings like the GCV  the brothers and sisters that they're  happy that you're here yes how about  your dad is he gonna come and visit you  want him to come visit  no Jonah what's going to happen with  that yeah is your relationship with him  sort of over or whatever happens happens  are you happy here you you how you  settling in yeah how you struggling with  the language you speaking a little bit  of Korean or yeah are you gonna be  staying in dorms or you're gonna be  staying in the dorms they were reporting  that maybe you've got an apartment in is  that right with that no business get the  business from where I'm from I'm from  London yeah southeast London the  business the last resort may clash yeah  if you think do you know if there's any  sort of our clubs like that here ok  great stuff ok thank you very much  [Music]